well the A's have an agreement to play
at the Las Vegas ballpark until their
Stadium near the strip quarters all
finished so what does that mean for
people and businesses next door in
downtown Summerlin that's where we find
Sasha Loftus live in Summerlin tonight
with more
Brian those we spoke with in Summerlin
tonight say they are ecstatic to be
right in the middle of all the action
this as Major League Baseball set to
start right here in their backyard
I love baseball I love sports excitement
is already in the air over the Oakland
Athletics move to Las Vegas I know
Oakland's not going to be happy but
those here in Summerlin are especially
ecstatic as the Las Vegas ballpark is
set to host the team until its official
stadium is finished in 2027 just being
able to be in the center of all this is
amazing Angela gardonio general manager
of sports Town USA in downtown Summerlin
says the arrival of the golden knights
the Aces and the Raiders have completely
changed things for them and she can't
wait to see what another major sports
team brings and it's just been so so
cool watching us go from a small kind of
Mom and Pop Shop one or two visitors an
hour to constant steady business another
big pull exposure with fans coming here
from across the country this place
really works well for what it is
something aviators president on Logan
says this facility is more than ready
for our fan base really responds as
you've seen you know we've got something
special here as we all prepare for yet
another Monumental change
to the city many are starting to call
the next Sports Mecca yeah
I think it'll do good
the Las Vegas aviators are the AAA
affiliate team of the Athletics so what
does that mean for them when the Ace
come here to the Las Vegas ballpark our
sports team will break that down in just
a few minutes here in this newscast
reporting live tonight Sasha Loftus 8
News Now